the truth is
the plane crashed a bunch of my friends
died
and then the rest of us starved and
scavenged
and prayed until they finally found us
i'm going into sunday like everybody
else at the season finale and i'm like
start eating people already when are you
going to start eating people i know we
agreed they know more than we have to
i'm also curious to see if we're gonna
like just eat people that have died or
are we gonna start like
murdering each other to like eat each
other like i'm curious to see if we're
gonna go completely wild because juliet
lewis said that it will be the peak of
disturbing during the finale it's insane
it's there's it's so much that happens
in the finale it's very
uh heartbreaking as well a lot of tears
we shed i think
what do you think
really happened out there explain to me
the feeling
when you realize that you're on one of
these shows
that just caught
like it just takes off what's that feel
like i actually started watching the
show and i think it's been fun to for
not every episode to come out and you
can't binge watch it i think it makes
you reflect on it during the week and
and i i know a lot of people are going
on reddit and have all these conspiracy
theories and i feel so bad because i
don't even have the answers myself
i think we both know there's more to it
than that if anything i think the fans
know more than me because they're making
connections that i don't even see and
then when i read them like oh
that actually does make sense thank you
for telling me this but obviously i mean
i'm thrilled we're all very happy about
the success of the show